FCC commissioner Brendan Carr is the man
raising the red flag here he joins me
now the justice department Brendan
recently sued SpaceX for
discriminatory hiring practices the SEC
has a uh probe going on into X um it
seems like there's a big swirl around
Elon Musk suddenly what's going on yeah
thanks much look I think it's obvious to
everyone What's Happening Here I think
it goes back to the White House last
year President Biden stood behind the
podium adorned with the official seal of
the president of the United States and
said that Elon Musk is worth being
looked at he was asked by a reporter how
the president looked down and said
there's a lot of ways and in fact there
are since then we've seen a deluge of
actions by the administrative State as
you noted the FAA the doj the FTC the
nlrb even the fish and wildlife services
have been looking into Elon Musk and as
you know that the FCC I we work just
this week we issued a decision that Rak
back a 2020 award of nearly $1 billion
dollar to bring high-speed internet
services to rural Americans in a
decision that simply doesn't make any
sense when viewed from the lens of the
facts or the law or the policy in fact
we made up an entirely new standard and
applied it to only one entity which was
Starling none of the other 180 entities
that won awards back in 2020 were held
to this standard it was simply moving
the goalposts well so that sounds like
the
definition of an unconstitutional move
by the federal government which is
essentially the equivalent of a of a a
law in this case a ruling against really
one company run by one man who they
don't like much for a whole bunch of
reasons but most of it's political yeah
look we're approaching 12 of the last 16
years where the administrative state has
been controlled by democrats and it
wields an awful lot of power and look
you could step back and say well Elon
Musk has a lot of businesses of course
he's going to have a lot of run-ins with
the government but look at these
decisions on their merits including just
the FCC one but you have the nlrb going
after Tesla for dress code violations
you have the FTC trying to get
information out reporters that got
access to information that ended up in
the Twitter files you got the fishing
wildlife services that was looking into
the fact that there was a Bob White
Quail EG and some blue land crabs that
were charred go after a SpaceX launch
that sounds more like surf and turf to
me than a than a federal case Mr
commissioner we're going to have you
back because this is I can't even
believe this is too wild to even
contemplate on a Friday night but you
gave us a bird's eye uh view into it
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else